a Georgia police department this morning
is investigating an officer caught on
video making a disturbing statement yeah
we always kill black people right the
Cobb County police officer who made the
controversial comments to a woman during
a traffic stop says he will retire but
his police chief wants to start the
process to fire him and Marie green is
here with the video that could cost a
veteran officer his career Emery good
morning good morning Vlad well the
dashcam video that has just been
released shows a traffic stop from July
of last year
the woman in the video who is white told
lieutenant Greg Abbott that she was
afraid to reach for her cellphone and
the officers response is not reassuring
during a traffic stop lieutenant Greg
Abbott can be heard telling a woman that
she needs to call the person who was
picking her up because she's being
arrested and taken to jail use your
phone it's in your lap
[Music]
but you're not black remember we only
have black people yeah we always feel
black people right Abbott's lawyer said
in a statement that the 27 year police
veteran was attempting to de-escalate
the situation after the woman said she
was afraid to retrieve her cell phone he
said
Abbott's comments must be observed in
their totality to understand their
context no matter what context she tried
to take those comments in the statements
were inexcusable and inappropriate
yesterday Police Chief Mike register who
was not chief at the time the video was
taken said the department has opened an
internal investigation I don't know
what's in his heart but I certainly know
what came out of his mouth CBS law
enforcement expert Paul viola says that
the woman was clearly in fear and
Abbot's comments were out of bounds if
you're really concerned about officer
safety ask her to step out of the
vehicle step back ask her to step in
front of the car retrieve what you want
underneath to see and then and then give
it to her but you certainly don't do
that
the incident occurred four days after
the death of falando Castile who was
shot five times by a Minnesota police
officer in a st. Paul suburb viola says
statements like Abbott's put up a wall
between police and the community we're
in a society today where police and
community are trying to mend and that
type of behavior is going to do nothing
but cause problems across the board
Abbott is currently off the Department
payroll and has been notified of his
proposed termination as a supervisor and
lieutenant Abbott was in charge of
reviewing the dashcam videos for his
unit which raised the questions about
why the video is just now coming to
light Maurice Emery thanks so much I got
a particular questions training suggest
a lot of other ways to defuse a
situation clearly yeah but what I don't
get is how watching it in its totality
would make that more understandable it's
more you hear the worst it actually gets
chief was right
it's what came out of his mouth I know
what else is there to hear